Speaker 1: So even though the prior president,
Donald Trump, was one of the most authoritarian
leaning dictator, wannabe presidents that
we've had in the modern political era, there
are people on the right, and this includes
Republican elected officials and this includes
some people and right wing media who want
you to believe that it is Joe Biden who is
about to imprison people, force people to
do this or to do that, regulate people into
oblivion, things that Joe Biden has actually
shown no interest in doing.
And one such example of this came to us from
Fox News a couple of days ago where Geraldo
Rivera was hosting something on Fox News and
he interviewed Fox and Friends, I guess, weekend
host Will Cain.
Will Cain is not like part of the big three
hosts of the weekday Fox and Friends, but
I guess he must be a weekend guy or a Phil
and guy.
And Will Cain showed up and said that soon
Americans who were not vaccinated against
covid-19 are going to be put in camps, sort
of like concentration camps, FEMA camps.
Remember, FEMA camps when Barack Obama was
president was a big thing.
And this was all part of being against masks
and being against vaccines and all of these
other things.
So let's listen to this together and see if
there's any evidence presented, actually.
Speaker 5: Welcome back.
As covid cases rage in several locations across
the country, the CDC telling unvaccinated
people not to travel over this Labor Day weekend
with CNN's Don Lemon going even further, pointing
this scolding message to those who still refuse
to get the shot.
Some people who are so selfish are saying
it's my freedom and I don't want to get vaccinated,
I want to do that.
OK, fine, but think about someone other than
yourself.
And if you don't believe that covid is real
and that can it can affect your health and
possibly take your life.
Don't go to the hospital.
Then when you get sick, don't go to the hospital
if you get sick.
That's a little harsh.
But isn't it isn't it logical to say that,
you know, vaccination plus mask equals travel
unvaccinated?
You know, isn't it prudent
Speaker 1: they don't even know what they're
talking about
Speaker 5: for unvaccinated people not to
travel?
Speaker 2: I would if I wasn't vaccinated.
I think this is a personal choice.
If I wasn't vaccinated, then I am a hermit.
I might just stay.
I might stay at home.
But that is a personal choice.
Unvaccinated people to vaccinate people.
If you got the shot, you should be fine.
But I want to
Speaker 1: really great medical analysis here
Speaker 2: shows and I'm actually not going
to steal this from Greg because I know Greg
has talked about this before, but this exposes
the combination of like dumb Asseri and cruelty
by Don Lemon because he's literally saying
if you smoked and you get lung cancer, you
don't get any treatment.
If you didn't work, if you didn't wear sunscreen,
you have melanoma, you don't get cancer treatment.
You ate too many cheeseburgers, no open heart
surgery for you.
So that's again, he's too stupid to be on
TV, but he's perfect for CNN.
Speaker 5: But there's two things going on
here, Bill.
And I know how deeply you feel about this.
Yeah.
There's the premise that unvaccinated people
should not travel because of the risk, the
exponential risk they pose to people, the
children, for example.
And the other thing is the cruelty of the
of the you know, the cavalier.
Well, don't go to the hospital bed if you
if you were that arrogant.
Speaker 1: Everybody sort of seems confused
on this segment if you can't tell vaccinated.
Speaker 5: But in terms of the first the you
know, the CDC is advising people, if you're
unvaccinated, don't travel.
So let me work that backwards.
Regarding the second point you made, whether
or not it's cruel, Dagan's exactly right.
We're veering dangerously close to exterminations
language.
Speaker 1: What why the extermination of the
rising determination?
Speaker 5: Absolutely.
That's the that's the next step.
Putting putting the unvaccinated into some
place else camps, whatever it may be.
When you listen to the cruelty of Don Lemon,
why
Speaker 1: is Will talking about the unvaccinated
are more likely to end up dead in the morgue
from covid than they are to end up in some
kind of camp for the unvaccinated?
This reminds me of, you know, like in high
school, in college, there was always some
kind a know it all who would have an epiphany
of some kind.
And they would they would rant.
And nobody really wants to argue with them.
So you just kind of go, mmm, OK.
All right.
Moving on that camps and extermination is
a that's what Will Cain is making me think
of here.
And remember that the predictions that they're
going to end up in camps have been going on
for a long time when Democrats have been president.
Remember, under Obama, they were going to
be FEMA camps and people were going to be
sent to FEMA camps, reeducation camps, etc.
It didn't happen.
It's just par for the course when a Democrat
is in the White House.
Now, meanwhile, Tucker Carlson claims that
the left just wants to kill unvaccinated people.
And his guest, Teddy Daniels, who's a former
officer, pro Trump military veteran, running
for something I think agrees.
Here is the left wants to kill the unvaccinated.
Know the vaccines are supposed to save people,
guys.
Speaker 5: Yeah, this is still America, Tucker.
OK, if if you want to wear a mask, wear a
mask.
Yeah, if if I if you don't want to wear a
mask, don't wear a mask.
That's what makes this country great with
the vaccines.
If you've had that conversation with your
doctor and you feel the vaccine is the best
route for you, go for it.
Cool, but for those that don't.
That's also cool, you know, let people live
their lives, we shouldn't we kill people who
don't get the vaccine.
Well, that's what the left wants to do.
Yeah, I've noticed.
You know, that's what what
Speaker 1: do people watch this stuff and
believe it?
I think to some degree they must.
The left wants to put into camps the unvaccinated
the left wants to kill the unvaccinated.
And the problem is that this stuff has worked
to weaponize disinformation, anti science
beliefs in a way that is preventing us from
actually dealing with the pandemic the way
we could.
Delta has been a problem essentially everywhere,
but there are countries that have dealt with
it far better countries that have higher vaccination
rates, countries where people are actually
following the medical guidelines and they
have turned it not just into medical guidelines,
they have turned it into a political battle
that they assessed to be life and death along
the wrong lines.
It is, in a sense, life, life or death.
Right?
I mean, we we know that your likelihood of
getting really sick from covid is way lower
if you're vaccinated.
We know that your likelihood of dying from
covered is way lower.
If you're vaccinated, it is life or death.
But they've got a completely different life
or death sort of battle line drawn.
And it's unfortunately worked really, really
well at convincing a lot of different people.